لا كان في انقطاع تام طبعا يختلف الموضوع
من سجل لسجن في بعض السجون
لنقل مراكز الاعتقال الاولى
من الممكن
بعض ما اقوم مضيفه فتره من الزمن يعني
يعني دائما في ناس جدد
وا هدول الناس الجدد بيحملوا لك اخبار
الخارجة لكن بالسجن تدمر انقطاع تام عن
الخارج نهائيا ولا حتى هؤلاء الجدد
بيكونوا بالسجون معتقلات اخرى حتى منقطعين
عن الخارج بيكون بالنسبه لكم الاخبار
جديده حتى لو مضى عليها
عن الخارج نهائيا لا
جريده لا كتاب لا راديو لا حتى قلم او
ورقه ممنوع كل هذا
المواظيفه انقطاع تام نهائي عن الخارجي
وصل بكم يوم في احد الايام من مواسم
الرياح المغبره التي ادت في سجن تدمر
الصحراوي عندما علقت جريده
جريده صفحه من جريده عند الشراقه المفتوحه
وكنتم تتمنون الا تذهب بها الرياح بعيدا
المهجع بالكامل كل الناس اللي موجودين
بالمهجه
انظار معلقه بعل الجريده طبعا في البدايه
كان دعاء وابتهال انه علل وعسى تنزل
لحالها يعني على المهجر خوفا من اي حركه
يعني يقوم فيها سجناء وانه الحارس ما يحس
فيها وانه الحارس ما يحس فيها نهائيا يعني
لكن رؤيه ما يحصل في معرفه ما يحصل في
الخارج او رؤيه لانه معظمهم كانوا متعلمين
بحد ذاته وانا هيك حكيت يعني الحرف
المطبوع بحد ذات بحد ذاته صار له سحر خاص
انه انت مانك شايف حرف مطبوع صار لك مثلا
سنتين ثلاثه خمسه عشره مانك شايف حرف
مطبوع نهائيا يعني هون الناس اللي موجودين
كلهم هن عباره عن الناس متعلمين ومثقفين
وقوادر واطباء ومهندسين يعني علاقتهم مع
الكتاب والحرف علاقه
وحميميه يعني حتى اشكالكم ما كنتم تقدروا
تشوفوها لان في مراه في نهائيا ابدا ما في
مرايا ما في مرايا يعني الا بعد ما يعني
بحالات معينه قديش ضل الانقطاع عن انه
واحد يشوف شكله حتى في المراه
هلا انا بالنسبه الي يمكن اربع سنوات وفي
حالات اخرى اكثر من ذلك حالات اخرى اكثر
من هيك بكثير يعني
اكرم الله السامعين وحضرتك كيف كان يحصل
ذلك
بمهاجع السجون الدائمه غير الاعتقاء يعني
مراكز الاعتقال الاولى في كل مهجاء في
تواليت
والسجناء نفسهم يعني يقتطعوا جزء من حيز
التواليت بيحاولوا الى حمام مشان ناس
يتحمم طبعا حمام بدائي الحنفيه ونعبي شي
وعاء ما نعبيه مي ونمسك شيء طاسه او شيء
وتواليت طبعا كان في معاناه انه مثلا انت
تكون مثلا 60 شخص بمهجع واحد بفيقوا الصبح
كلياتهم تواليت واحد فعاده بالدور